ethereum 2.0
is an upgraded ethereum and everybody
knows about it
but everyone is curious to know when
this upgrade is going to be released
so they could take advantage of its more
efficient and enhanced resources
hey everyone i am shanghi and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on ethereum 2.0 in this video
we will explore ethereum 2.0 and will go
through some of the fascinating concepts
and components revolving around it
first we will have a quick introduction
of what is ethereum network
then we will look into what ethereum 2.0
is
then we will understand what led to the
origin of ethereum 2.0
then we will understand the changes in
ethereum 2.0
then we will look into the current
status of ethereum 2.0 research
and at last what future we expect for
ethereum 2.0
so without doing much ado let's get
started with the video
so what is the ethereum network ethereum
is defined as a blockchain based
computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy decentralized application
ether is the cryptocurrency for ethereum
used to build decentralized application
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions
and make sure they are cryptographically
secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades
that will make the ethereum network more
secure scalable
and sustainable multiple teams
from across the ethereum ecosystem have
come together to work on these upgrades
in ethereum 2.0
then what led to the region of ethereum
2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network
has gotten more blocked by transactions
currently
it is capable of handling 15 to 45
transactions per second
which is comparatively impressive but it
is not enough
to handle all of italian's users
worldwide
also the high demand is affecting the
driving up of transaction fees
nodes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently
its nodes are experiencing too much
volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed
that making its nodes bigger wouldn't be
practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable
to handle all of the activities on the
ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.0
the two significant changes that will
come
with the upgrade are adopting proof of
stake and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations
suffer from performance issues because
they rely on a processing power
intensive process
known as proof of work to record and
validate their transactions
the problem with proof-of-work design is
that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning
its blockchain to a more efficient
proof-of-stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to
massive throughput gains for the whole
network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency
and ability to scale in the current
version of ethereum blockchain
all data that is added to the chain
undergoes verification by all
participating nodes
that means that the speed of its fluids
participant
limits the processing speed of the
entire network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources
by breaking data verification tasks
among its set
of nodes and each of them will be
responsible
for validating and verifying just the
data allotted to them
this will increase the network's overall
capacity and make it much faster
and efficient than its outdated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
while ethereum 2.0 has been in research
and development
since 2014. it has actually been making
some progress
the beacon chain went live in december
2020 introducing this taking concept
but still there is no official claim for
the completion of this transition
the next phase is mainnet merging the
beacon chain
into the current ethereum network mining
ethereum tokens
will officially end in this phase and
staking will become the primary way
to create new tokens in the ethereum
network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the sharp chains to give the
ethereum blockchain network
more capacity and efficiency to handle
all of the demand
and increased transactions per second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated
and on their way to completing the whole
transition so
what is the future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0
could be a total game changer it will
create a modified network
that could potentially process one lag
transactions per second
and a much more sustainable network
without the energy intensive mining
process
and it will introduce smart contracts
worldwide increasing the ethereum's
network utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
alex buduran once
said that the issuance of new token
should be highly reduced under ethereum
2.0
which could increase its demand given
all these factors ethereum 2.0 seems to
hold a bright future for ethereum
blockchain network
so this is all about ethereum 2.0 we
have almost reached
the end of this video if i missed
anything important
do let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on italian
2.0
and learn something new from it if you
like this video then please do hit the
like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos
from simply not
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here